The current Ebola virus outbreak in West Africa
is the largest and most wide spread in History,
with over 21,000 known cases to date and counting.
Let's reveal some surprising facts about this
deadly virus.
1.
The first known instance of Ebola was in 1976.
It appeared in Zaire in the Democratic Republic
of the Congo and killed 280 people.
2.
But the 1976 case may not be the first outbreak.
A study on infectious diseases suggested the
first outbreak of Ebola may have occurred
around 430 B.C. in ancient Greece.
The writings of Thucydides, described a virulent
disease that wiped out half of the city.
His description of the disease's symptoms
is very similar to Ebola, including uncontrollable
bleeding.
3.
Ebola is named after the Ebola River in the
Democratic Republic of the Congo, which is
60 miles away from the first ever case of
the virus.
4.
In the current outbreak a handful of West
African countries have been infected, and
9 non-African countries.
Spain, Germany, France, Switzerland, Netherlands,
Norway, Italy, the UK and the USA.
5.
Past Ebola outbreaks have had fatality rates
of up to 90%.
But the fatality rate of the current outbreak
in West Africa it 50%.
However outside of Africa, the fatality rate
is much lower.
The current fatality rate in the United States
and Europe is a significantly lower 20%.
Proving that where you're treated makes an
enormous difference.
6.
Ebola is not airborne and therefore cannot,
in its current form, be transmitted through
the air, via coughing or sneezing.
It also can't be transmitted through water.
The virus can only be transmitted through
direct contact with the blood or body fluids
of an Ebola sufferer.
This makes Ebola surprisingly difficult to
spread, when compared to more contagious diseases
such as Measles or Influenza.
7.
Because of this many disease specialists have
said that Ebola poses no threat to wealthier
countries in Europe and North America because
of their higher hygiene standards and better
disease containment capabilities.
8.
2014 is not the first time in history that
Ebola has appeared in the United States.
In 1989, macaque monkeys in the primate unit
of Hazelton Research Product's lab in Reston,
Virginia, began dying with Ebola like symptoms.
Four workers were exposed to the virus and
the military and CDC were called in to eliminate
the monkeys and quarantine the humans.
But strangely it appeared to be a new strain
of Ebola that was only lethal to primates.
The new strain did however display a frightening
ability to go airborne for the first time.
9.
There is currently no tried and tested vaccine
for Ebola but in September 2014, a clinical
trial of a new potential Ebola vaccine was
able to protect monkeys against the virus
in 100% of cases.
The same vaccine has just begun a trial at
Oxford University on humans, for the first
time ever.
If the trials are successful the company that
manufactures the virus says it could have
2 million doses of the vaccine available this
year.
10.
Several potential cures for the Ebola virus
are also currently being developed and tested.
One of the most promising is called ZMapp.
It was given to seven Ebola patients, two
of whom died.
Showing a reasonable success rate.
But the drug is difficult and time consuming
to make.
And the limited supply has now been exhausted.
It will take several months to manufacture
a new batch.
However seven other potential Ebola cures
are currently undergoing clinical trials.
11.
There are five known strains of the Ebola
virus.
These strains are called Zaire, Sudan, Taï
Forest, Reston and Bundibugyo.
Named after the locations of each strain's
patient zero.
A person who survives an Ebola infection is
then immune to that particular strain but
is still susceptible to the other four strains.
12.
One of the biggest challenges facing the containment
of the Ebola outbreak is misinformation and
distrust of health professionals in West Africa.
Many sufferers of Ebola don't seek medical
care as they fear going into isolation and
being around other ebola patients.
This vastly increases the chance of the individual
transmitting the virus to friends and family.
There is also a tradition in West Africa of
washing dead bodies before burial.
This has vastly increased the rate of infection
and is a significant issue in the current
outbreak.
Because Ebola can live on a patient's skin
for several days after death.
Meaning you could get infected from simply
touching the corpse of an Ebola victim then
touching your mouth or eyes.
13.
It is still not known where Ebola actually
comes from, but evidence suggests that fruit
bats are the natural carriers of the disease.
Research suggests that the patient zero of
the current outbreak was a 2-year-old in Guinea,
who had recently been playing in a bat tree
when he contracted the disease.
Known as bushmeat, bats and other wild animals
are frequently eaten by natives of Guinea
and bat soup is a delicacy in the region,
which could also have contributed to the start
of the current Ebola outbreak.